trong bởi người an vài bài kế vang, dùng đề mùi nhà và đất mùi năm trước,
sơ chả tính gia tiền thử giả trị kế vai chiế sâu ý kiến bị đối tịch tọn với người nhà.
Mới đây, có chuyện của một tại khoảng có tin đời đời đời đời đời đời đất tại trên một trong kiến
đã kể giả trân cả y sức ất nè tây dành. Thế chia sẻ của chị lời,
cách đề mùi năm, em chồng của chị ở người an mùi nhà như không buổi tiền.
Hoải phai bởi chúng chị, khi đó ra đình chị lời đã có nhà cử đăng hoang,
nên nghĩ sức ảnh lúc khó khăn, thế lất có bao nhiêu tại sản để giảm chồng phải hết.
Lúc đó, chỉ lời nghĩ rằng cho vai vang thì sau này không bị mất sả,
với lại không cho vai thì cũng chỉ cất cho cách, nên vô tư không nghĩ gì.
Tư bởi đến sự em chồng không nói chuyện trả nữ,
con chị lời thì cũng chưa cần dùng đến số vang đó đến cũng không đời.
Đến năm nay, khi con gái chị lời chừng bị mua nhà,
đây này vợ trong định sẽ cho con số vang và em chồng vai.
Hãy chị lời hỏi sin lại số vang đã cho vai em chồng có vẻ không buổi
và nói sẽ thu sép để trả.
Tư yên, sự việc đã sửa nên con thần khi có em chồng trả nạn chỉ lời
bằng tiền thân ra chị bởi kế vang thời điểm cách kế mùi năm,
thông hần dất nhiều sống của dạ chị hình tại.
Chỉ lời đã không đồng ý cách tình như vậy,
tiêm trong nói rằng, đời chả bởi kế vang lúc lại chả khách nào trong người nhà vai năng lại.
Lúc vai vang cũng phải bán vang đi để chả tế mua nhà,
nên ra chị tình thật tìm thật trên chứ không phải vang.
Nếu chị lời cứ nhất quyết lời chả bởi kế vang,
con chồng sẽ chả những dễ cất tích tự giữ sổ thiệt.